hi my name is Tanana Reeve I am an
author and screenwriter I'm an executive
producer on shudders horror noir and I
teach a black horror class at UCLA
called the sunken place racism survival
and the black horror aesthetic today I'm
going to give you an overview of the
history of black horror films so my love
for horror like a lot of black women I
know started at a young age because my
mother loved horror
my late mother was a civil rights
activist she was my first Shiro and in
fact had a tear gas canister thrown in
her face so she wore dark glasses the
whole time I knew her as an adult I
mentioned that because my mother
suffered trauma I began to realize that
my mother was using horror movies as a
way to soothe her trauma and anger and
fear out of not just the civil rights
movement but racial trauma in the United
States something pretty extraordinary
happened in in very recent years Jordan
Peele released his oscar-winning
screenplay but the film was called get
out which was a black horror story by a
black creator a black story told through
a black lens which was very different
than the horror that I had been seeing
up to that point it's a really really
exciting time to be a horror creator and
a horror fan and I am personally seeing
the impact of that but it has been a
long road to this point this is not
where we started so I'd like to go back
a little bit and talk about the history
of black horror and film so we can all
have a better idea of how significant it
is that we are where we are today but
when we look at the history of black
horror films and blacks in horror films
dr. Robin R means Coleman and her book
Horne waar does make a distinction
between black horror which is black
created in black driven horror and
blacks in the horror which is non black
creators where often we are ill used
let's look at something that you might
not even consider a horror film The
Birth of a Nation DW Griffith's film
which was the first Hollywood
blockbuster it reigned in movie theaters
as like the top box office
for all intents and purposes a
generation it was the most popular film
in the country and unfortunately encoded
in that film is some very toxic imagery
and some very toxic propaganda propping
up the Confederacy and even worse than
that the Ku Klux Klan
so the remnants of the Confederacy which
are these masked Avengers basically
White's dressed up in hoods this was
popularized in the I mean the burning of
the crosses and all this became sort of
a template for how domestic terrorism
could look but for movie goers who were
not black this was not considered
domestic terrorism this was just justice
this was the natural order so starting
in 1915 with the birth of a nation that
would be blacks in horror although a lot
of them weren't even black it was just
white actors in blackface
but that was showcasing black
monstrosity they're gonna rise up
they're gonna steal your women they're
gonna take your jobs or whatever and
we're still sort of under the cloud of
that propaganda from 1915 today in many
ways as we tried to move away from those
stereotypes so then jump ahead to the
1940s where finally
filmmaker Spencer Williams wrote some of
em GOG II the first black science
fiction horror film which is black
driven black characters doctor lawyer
weddings all kinds of middle-class
respectability they try to counteract
all those stereotypes you can contrast
that to the movie that came out of here
later in 1941 king of the zombies
starring mantan Moreland this is comic
horror
man Tim Marlon was very well known
terrific performer but unfortunately
spent a lot of his time having to make
buggy eyes and feets don't fail me now
and the black you know have to be saved
by the white man so these this is a
battle two sides trying to tell the
story of blacks and horror moving beyond
the 40s we disappeared a great deal in
the 50s by the time you get to the 60s
there's a breakout performance of Dwayne
Jones and
the Living Dead he won the role of the
protagonist Ben Ben ends up in a in a
room basically this with his white woman
Barbara they're coming to get you
Barbara that line so Ben ends up with
Barbara Barbara is in shock at one point
they she slaps him he hits her back in
1968 and to have a black protagonist not
only the Alpha and in charge of all this
group of characters in the house but
killing all these white zombies I'm
thinking that that looked pretty
disturbing just racist moviegoers in
particular whereas black movie goers are
like wow it's it's going on here oh my
gosh so exciting the 1970s is the growth
of the blaxploitation era this is when
black filmmakers were having an
opportunity to really tell their own
version of a horror story so instead of
Dracula you get Blacula
William Crain directed this is a very
young director he took it in a direction
that the filmmakers the studio wasn't
really comfortable with adding African
history and he has characters that their
names are in Swahili
but the filmmaker was trying to elevate
the material above what we had seen
previously
so the 1970s saw the gamut of black
horror from black creators where in a
film like a B it's a black woman who's
possessed by sort of a sex demon again
not always the best messages but at
least was an opportunity for black
filmmakers to show themselves and film
and and and to move beyond the worst
stereotypes that we had seen in previous
eras so the 1980s were the double-edged
sword of representation like yay there
is more of us in the films but because
the financing models had moved away from
the blaxploitation era where films were
just going to show in black
neighborhoods for black audiences once
you sort of globalized
moviemaking that's when you start to see
those parts really shrinking for the
black characters and becoming trophy so
your background character
you're sassy characters you're gonna die
if you're not dying first you're
definitely gonna die second or third
you're generally not going to make it
until the end of the movie and we start
to see more of those stereotypes of the
magical negro the sacrificial negro the
spiritual guide emerging in the 80s so
the magical negro is that character
often characterizes other usually you're
the only person of color in the movie
and you're the one with all the answers
you're the character the white
characters go to for all their magical
needs the sacrificial negro is that
character who will throw him or herself
in harm's way literally jump in front of
the monster to save the white characters
some of the most obvious examples of
those tropes showing up in films in the
80s or The Shining
Stanley Kubrick's Shining in 1980 where
dick Halloran the character played by
Scatman Crothers who survives in Stephen
King's novel actually ends up getting an
axe of a jet the minute he walks through
the door by Jack Nicholson in the film
version classic sacrificial negro the
early 2000 2001 had an example of a
magical Negro in the film Jeepers
Creepers where again a black woman is
showing up pretty randomly to give
advice and putting herself at risk to
try to save the white characters and
convinced them that she knows about the
creature that's stalking them luckily
she does survive but she came this close
to being a sacrificial negro too
the 90s were an amazing film Renaissance
all through film including horror so you
had directors getting opportunities to
tell their stories rusty Cundieff tales
from the hood really stands out from
1995 for short horror stories a lot of
them
revenge oriented a lot of them a plea
for sometimes a plea for the black
community to do better within its homes
or within its communities but also lots
of payback for evil racist cops or for
racist politicians beyond tales from the
hood there's also Casey lemons beautiful
film Eve's Bayou which is mostly a drama
but it has tinges of Voodoo and the
horror is in the home it's a story of
young
and her coming of age and really loss of
innocence as she begins to wonder if her
philandering father played by Samuel
Jackson might have had inappropriate
contact with her sister and she believes
that she created a voodoo spell to kill
him contrasting that would be the 1990s
version of Candyman which was not by a
black filmmaker although it did star the
iconic actor Tony Todd as Candyman and I
talked to Tony Todd and I know that that
role was a sense of pride for a lot of
young blacks especially probably a young
black man who saw him as strong and
powerful and charge of his own destiny
but civil rights groups were not happy
at the time of the idea of a black
serial killer basically which is what
Candyman was especially I think because
he was plaguing his own community that
Cabrini Green projects in Chicago so
even though candy mans backstory was
that he had basically been mauled and
and killed by racists because of his
love for a white woman when he comes
back he's attacking a black housing
project
Candyman was considered problematic and
it's day although it really does still
stand out as one of the iconic horror
films we also started to see the
emergence of black women and horror in
bigger roles alien versus Predator came
out and Sanaa Lathan is a badass it
might like to say that a 2002 R&B star
Aaliyah was in Queen of the Damned and
in not a lead role but a great role so
nice representation we're starting to
see it just a little bit more but it's
also just sprinkles here and there so
with this sort of hit and miss history
there wasn't really a congealed idea of
what black horror was going into the
2010s
until Jordan Peele created get out which
has just opened the door and opened
imaginations so that people like me who
create horror and people who were just
fans of horror finally have an
opportunity to just be like everybody
else
whether it's about race or not about
race so get out obviously racism is the
mom
stur us the follow-up to get out not so
much it's more about class although it
is still revolutionary that Pele
intentionally cast that movie with black
actors first of all horror is like any
other film genre in the sense that
representation matters our films as a
culture should look like our nation this
is kind of a no-brainer but it's been a
long journey they can learn to empathize
with us in the islands scream on our
behalf and that's in US and other
marginalized groups and queer characters
there's room for everybody I think as a
culture we all just need to learn how to
see the humanity in each other and I'm
just really grateful that we've reached
the time when we can show our more of
our full measure of humanity on film all
this to say especially all of you
creators out there don't listen to the
naysayers who tell you don't waste your
time while writing horror or writing
science fiction there has never been a
better time to be a black horror creator
and I can't wait to see the stories
you'll tell
[Music]